nine minutes the other night Caruso
again don't Lonzo obviously so he's got
opportunity look at that floater up and
over that glass going on easier moment
the spotlight is on you Mr curry sighs
the defender knew he had him under
control - spoon shot
long rebound off the yield Lakers are
running Caruso let's see what happens
when you push the ball he not expected
results is Caruso running the wing and I
mean and he attacked with a purpose
great job Bart for three Theresa
[Applause]
the floor now going to the dribble parks
and Kotik Caruso Caruso throws it down
hammer time with one hand I mean he
cocked that one too he put that one way
back behind his head and said come get
it
no James 7 turnovers for New York Jew
for the Lakers
Caruso down the middle he goes and he
scores it through so I be shrived the
other night he should be on a freeze all
about Hollins
[Music]
BeeZee just ran through Caruso boxing
with Lee right on trying to go say
[Music]
something Caruso pill they all know how
Jordan Clarkson that time Jordan was in
difficulty but because of the of the
dive he gives the assist numbers-wise
without question best game of his short
Laker career Alex Caruso I just love it
when he plays with aggression slam dunks
at home he's done that more than a
couple of times already this year
McDermott Okaloosa that should have been
on his shoulder it's gonna be Laker ball
what a play by Alex Caruso we didn't
quit on the play even though zoo came
out to Hill Alex Caruso that's the pass
of the year for the Lakers nice he did
that so nonchalantly that's why none of
the Bucks were able to read it we didn't
Telegraph that one all beautifully done
Lakers on a 12-2 dances Julius Lookaway
pass to Caruso reverse layup
good thinking Crescent think aggressive
Caruso nice job of attacking Derrick
Favors Oh a couple of poops successive
trips
one-possession game as I've said alters
can be better than blah that was a
beautiful bounce pass beautiful bounce
pass as Tyson Chandler goes out and
congratulate s'
JaVale on the defensive side and LeBron
gets yet another assist with a sparkling
bounce pass to Caruso who throws it up
Russo oh there's a quality mate that's
for sure Caruso the pleasant they review
it but a three-pointer for Caruso with
both of his threes first quarter
complete here at Salt Lake City jazz
lead is 7 o.a largest lead 20 right now
16 as we open the floor it's all what a
nice pass Caruso throws it down that's
that's a backdoor lob we've seen pro run
for Alonzo that is a big-time play by
crook Scavo
Williams again attacks in
early offense though they don't have to
bear out there to protect the rim steal
make sure did you see yeah boo so Time
Warner dumped out one five point game
again we talked about his ability to get
to the basket his sneaky athleticism and
OKC finds himself in a game right now
Ferguson drive to the basket Paul George
but to check back in but magic number
four told him state is three Rondo three
[Applause]
oh my goodness fact that is punster
ready he just put the Warriors all on a
team poster nine to shoot
to loose on the Lakers in the fourth
quarter he's going to go to the rim he
does it again look at the broad out to
midcourt to meet Caruso underhand scoop
high off the window and it's nothing the
bottom what a game for Caruso talked
about his viral
[Applause]
Patroni show good job again hit his bin
on a flat angle pass great job of using
your hands
good defense by LBJ but then nobody
there to pick up the pieces
caldwell-pope Rousseau didn't know your
daddy's bag did you
well alex caruso is more athletic than
you think and he worked hard on his body
goes to the room with authority and
leaves no doubt hall-of-fame jerseys up
there i think they should put the Hall
of Fame coaches you want a title there's
jarvan's Jackson a lot of sheets of
three all three of those should be on
the banner up there when he attacks now
I mean the last year so he really goes
with aggression not trying to be cute so
they get the Carruth show early in the
first quarter past his luvin2travel in
his hair with a little jumper to the
zone the ball attack
there he goes again a nice ERISA throw
it down with to me
the printer attacked him it wasn't in
his balance to get drunk by block by
time these other day Lakers lead
I blocked shots nearly eight again we
had seven the other night get the handle
the same dude the big fella
out of the show on a great feed maybe he
pretended like he was going to Rondo on
that play did a great job of looking off
to the fender but all of a sudden Caruso
is available open path for the rim the
delivery by Davis and the finish by
Caruso
he took that one away from Dwight to
throw it down
[Applause]
[Music]
by properly but what a play by AC with
this crowd as the Lakers always
represented quite well on the road
tandem with ad on the defensive end
[Applause]
Minnesota needs a timeout
right here 100 to 84 biggest lead of the
game good job on the defensive end yet
again as they keep making these stops
and get out in and say that they will
display 12 games against the West here
is Alex Avila is sweet Alex Caruso
Riversleigh turned a corner and they let
him go into car anthe towns of defensive
rating the Russos spin
all the way score alex caruso
much-needed who grew so look he's at the
top of the key sees the shot clock it
was about an eighth when you got started
and who says I better go to work for the
Lakers just like the way they play team
boards in that scenario nice little drop
pass by Rondo with a bounce pass through
the two defenders as we look at the
defense at the Lakers have been putting
on an exhibition first was the play
where Drummond faked and then when he
went up usage of the window by Caruso
after falling behind 79 74
[Applause]
time out Misty's the Lakers had a 4-0
break there Caruso gets the dunk and
LeBron is jump hired in Caruso did on
his dunk until my crease warming in the
Drummond and look at the Lakers go it
knocks it down
[Applause]
nice dribble drive he acted like he was
gonna make a dribble handoff and the
defender would played it that way and he
goes right in for the dump job of
cutting off the angle of the shot blocks
of people Cleveland I mean that was just
a nice plate of just brush contact puts
him off-balance but he gets the hoop he
has a three-point opportunity
great job by Caruso surface fake by AC
fell they're gonna keep it real
valuating him on a day-to-day basis but
it does seem like a closer look around a
little bike an emphatic slam fight white
after yet another good pass from AC what
a crew so turned the corner and really
set the table very effectively for
Dwight that time as David Bradley picks
up a quick crowd his pass Caruso
deflects it James right back to Caruso
back to James and it's an eight-point
game
Caruso is at four steals in about three
or four other deflections almost gets
another that's a quick whistle they tie
it up but guru so once again the same
zombies got a five time out cold by the
Rockets right there defensively picked
up by Alex all the way tourism the
Lakers benefited from not being called
but it looked like Caruso got found at
midcourt they reached out and just try
to slow his progress would have been in
smart foul to 341 to play in the quarter
Carles cam will show that flying fair
the turnover at Caruso grabs it any
right there boy I tell you it just
emphasizes the lack of fundamentals all
you have to do is boxy mile they don't
box him out and he gets a highlight play
off of a missed free throw for the
runway against Howard Danny
got a hand on it now Caruso runs a break
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
heart the flyby good pass ball Caruso
at the top hole that's out of bounds off
a ball Laker basketball on a thrilling
rejection by Caruso to get that Lea ball
turns it over collision was teammate
disguise
let it smart